[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir je m'appelle arnaud août
et je suis professeur de français à
l'institut don bosco en belgique
je m'appelle jérôme piron je suis
professeur de philosophie dans la même
école alors on a tous les deux fait des
études de linguistique et un jour au
cours de ses études on est tombé sur une
citation
est-ce que vous surveillez votre
orthographe est ce que vous surveillez
l'orthographe des autres
alors il faut quand même bien
reconnaître une chose c'est qu'en
français on est particulièrement peu
exigeants avec l'orthographe on parle
pas de votre orthographe ni de la nôtre
d'ailleurs ni même de celle de kevin
notre régisseur qui a une orthographe
bien à lui non en français on est
particulièrement peu exigeants avec
l'orthographe elle même oui s'il arrive
qu'on juge votre orthographe
on ne juge pratiquement jamais
l'orthographe elle même alors attention
il ne s'agit pas ici de juger la langue
mais bien son orthographe
souvent on a tendance à confondre
l'orthographe et la langue elle-même
mais l'orthographe c'est pas la langue
l'orthographe c'est l'écriture de la
langue et c'est même pas d'écriture en
termes de style ou de qualité de phrases
en fait c'est le code graphique qui
permet de transmettre donc de
retranscrire la langue orale c'est un
petit peu comme les partitions qui sont
au service de la musique
l'orthographe n'est qu'un outil au
service de la langue
alors si l'orthographe est un outil on
sait simplement poser une question avec
arnaud est ce que c'est un bon outil
prenons par exemple le son comme
régisseur
comment peut-on écrire ce sont en
français on peut l'écrire s2 sccc 10s
c'est comme dans science t les finales
mention on peut l'écrire x dans dix ou
six bruxelles
on peut l'écrire z dans mon quartz ou
aztèques
on peut l'écrire th dans forsythia
on peut l'écrire sth dans isme pour
asthme
on peut l'écrire de ses dents succion et
on peut même l'écrire scc dit dans il
acquiesça alors maintenant maintenant si
vous voyez la lettre s écrite comment
est ce qu'elle se prononce soit soit
entre deux voyelles soit pas muette
donc ça fait 1 sont 12 manière de
l'écrire une lettre trois façons de la
prononcer en
[Applaudissements]
alors en turc en turc l'orthographe est
parfaitement phonétique une lettre un
son un son une lettre mayonnaise
saucisse encore un donc en turc
quand vous entendez un mot pour la
première fois vous savez automatiquement
comment il s'écrit et c'est le cas dans
beaucoup d'autres langues comme le
bulgare le finnois le serbe le roumain
et c'est pratiquement le cas du
néerlandais de l'italien de l'espagnol
de l'allemand ou du russe
comparons à présent avec le français en
français si on inventait un mot qui
n'existe pas comme le mot créé fission
qu'on a inventé avec jérôme créé fusion
de combien de manière différente
pourrait-on écrire ce nouveau mot créé
fission en français alors pour répondre
à cette question
kevin a écrit un petit programme un
algorithme qui permet de calculer toutes
les orthographes possible du mot créé
fission en français kévin
[Applaudissements]
voilà au total il existe deux cent
quarante manière différente et écrire le
mot créé fission en français on se
demande souvent comment respecter
l'orthographe mais l'orthographe elle
même et elle respectable en français en
écrit le mot bruit le mot est dit ou le
mot crédit avec thé pour faire bruitées
édités ou crédité mais pas abri
on écrit 10 avec un x comprenons ce s
alors qu'on écrit une dizaine avec un z
et un dixième qu'on écrit x mais qu'on
prononce z
employé avec employés avec l'auxiliaire
avoir le participe passé s'accordent en
genre et en nombre avec le complément
d'objet direct quand celui ci le
précèdent les crêpes que j'ai mangé es
par contre quand le complément suit le
participent
il reste invariable j'ai mangé et les
crêpes
alors pourquoi pourquoi avant mais pas
après au moyen âge les moines ont des
conditions de travail difficiles ils
travaillent dans des monastères mal
chauffés mal éclairé avec des plumes
d'animaux souvent sous la dictée quand
le moine écrivait par exemple les pieds
que jésus à laver mais un simple regard
vers la gauche permet d'identifier ce
que jésus à laver il avait quoi les
pieds donc le moine accorde pas de
problème par contre quand le moins
l'écrivait jésus à laver mais il se dit
jésus à laver quoi je sais pas je vais
attendre ça va probablement revenir dans
la suite du texte
avant la fête de pâques
sachant que son heure était venue
lorsque le diable avait déjà inspiré au
coeur de judas iscariote fils de simon
le dessein de le livrer sur les bords du
lac de tibériade et patati et patata
les pieds voilà
à tous les coups quand le moins elle est
arrivée à un les pieds il a oublié qu'il
avait un participe à accorder ou alors
il n'a plus la place pour écrire la
lettre parce qu'au moyen-âge les mots
sont souvent attachés les uns aux autres
essais de l'observation de cet oubli
donc de cette erreur particulièrement
fréquentes dans les manuscrits du moyen
âge qu'on a attiré la règle voilà
pourquoi avant mais pas après alors à
l'école à l'école les enfants se demande
pourquoi pourquoi avant et pas après
pourquoi x pourquoi pas de théa abri
mais quand les enfants demandent
pourquoi on leur explique comment
comment on écrit ou comment on accorde
pourquoi est ce que l'esprit critique
s'arrête au seuil de l'orthographe et
bien c'est parce qu'on a tous appris à
ne plus se demander pourquoi alors
pourquoi l'orthographe du français est
elle si compliqué parce que en réalité
ne tombe pas comme ça un jour du ciel
tout fait
elle a une histoire avant le xviie
siècle tout le monde écrit comme il veut
montaigne ou rabelais avaient leur
propre orthographe qui variait
d'ailleurs d'un manuscrit à l'autre ou
d'un imprimeur à l'autre molière
lui-même dans une des toutes premières
éditions du misanthrope
écrivain misanthrope 100h d'ailleurs
molière écrivait orthographe 100h en
fait aujourd'hui plus personne ne lit
molière dans l'orthographe de molière
elle a été adaptée au fil des rééditions
sans que cela ne change absolument rien
à son oeuvre
donc il ne faut pas confondre la langue
de molière et son orthographe
[Applaudissements]
alors d'où vient cette obsession
contemporaine pour l'orthographe au
xviie siècle on centralise l'état et
richelieu réalise que la langue est un
pouvoir
il crée alors l'académie française
l'académie aura pour mission de rédiger
un dictionnaire pour fixer la norme en
réalité aujourd'hui l'académie française
est une fausse référence il n'y a pas de
linguistes à l'académie française
c'est un petit peu comme s'il n'y avait
pas de mécaniciens au contrôle technique
non académicien est un titre honorifique
pas scientifique
il ne suffit pas d'enfiler un habit vert
pour devenir grammairien en fait dès
l'origine au xviie siècle
l'académie va surtout faire de la norme
la marque de l'appartenance à la bonne
société
le bon usage oui en même temps à
l'époque pas grand-monde n'écrit et il
faut vraiment attendre le 19e siècle
pour que l'orthographe devienne une
norme incontournable c'est la
bourgeoisie montante qui va donner à
l'orthographe ses lettres de noblesse
elle va revendiquer une orthographe
délibérément compliqué l'académie
française va d'ailleurs introduire dans
son dictionnaire de 1835 toute une série
de consonnes doubles de consonnes
étymologique qui n'existait pas
auparavant
oui et surtout on va l'imposer à tous
de plus en plus d'enfants vont à l'école
et l'orthographe devient le principal
critère pour sélectionner les
instituteurs et puis tous les concours
d'accès à la fonction publique passe par
une dictée oui c'est aussi l'époque de
l'avènement des nationalismes et ont
fait de la langue un enjeu identitaire
on veut un français le même pour tous
unique et indivisible à l'image de la
république une et indivisible
l'orthographe comme ciment de la nation
et depuis à chaque fois qu'on propose de
modifier l'orthographe
ça provoque parfois quelques réticences
souvent essentiellement parce qu'on a le
sentiment qu'on va s'attaquer à un
héritage
si on prend les consonnes étymologique
qui viennent du latin et du grec était
haché ph comme dans philosophe par
exemple
y toucher ce serait un peu comme s'en
prendre au patrimoine
d'une certaine manière se couper d'une
partie de l'histoire de la langue
française
mais cette histoire est largement
fantasmée d'abord pourquoi est-ce qu'on
a conservé ou introduit uniquement les
consonnes étymologique issu du latin et
du grec bas parce que ça fait classe
parce qu'on aimerait croire que le
français ne descend que de l'antiquité
mais en réalité on a évacué sans hésiter
toutes les consoles étymologique issus
des langues germaniques de l'arabe de
l'italien
rien que ces trois langues là c'est déjà
35 % de tous les maux qu'on a emprunté
en français si on voulait vraiment
respecté l'étymologie pourquoi pas mais
dans ce cas on devrait écrire par
exemple le mot style avec un i parce
qu'on l'a emprunté au latin style ou si
on n'a pas emprunté aux grecs
par contre il ya un mot qu'on a emprunté
aux grecs c'est le mot économie donc
pour respecter son origine on devrait
écrire comme foetus ou encore le mot
fantômes qui vient aussi du grec
fantasmes et puis est-ce qu'on peut
sérieusement accuser les italiens ou les
espagnols de souffrir d'un déficit
culturel parce que en italien on écrit
par exemple filosofo avec des f
depuis toujours et ça n'a quand même
jamais empêché les italiens de faire de
l'étymologie de retrouver les origines
philo et sofia alors parfois certains
donnent aussi à l'orthographe
une dimension esthétique en effet on
peut trouver que c'est beau parce que
c'est compliqué on peut appeler toutes
les absurdités de l'orthographe des
subtilités et être fier de cette
spécificité de la langue française
mais si on a le droit trouvait qu'une
forme est belle et d'avoir envie de la
garder
alors on a droit l'a trouvée laide
pourquoi les mots du dictionnaire
devrait-il tous être beau à la rigueur
on pourrait même envisager de les rendre
encore plus beau
le collège de pataphysique boris vian
alfred jarry avait imaginé ce qu'ils
appelaient une orthographe d'apparat
alors qu'est ce que c'est une
orthographe d'apparat pour vous
l'expliquer kevin nous a programmé ici
une petite application qui est un module
de reconnaissance vocale en orthographe
d'apparat que voici est donc dans cette
orthographe par exemple leçon à ses
écrits comme dans le mode doit
comme dans le goret ou diarrhée au
capharnaüm cherchez pas il y en a qu'un
2 amygdales tu peux faire un truc un peu
plus long projet d'orthographe d'apparat
[Applaudissements]
alors il existe encore une raison de
défendre une orthographe compliqué le
sens de l'effort comme c'est compliqué
cet exigeant et cette exigence apprend à
nos enfants à se dépasser
les gens ont l'impression que si on
simplifie on va faire moins d'efforts
mais on va pas faire moins on va faire
mieux
évidemment c'est difficile de dire à
ceux qui ont souffert qu'ils ont
souffert pour rien
[Applaudissements]
tout le temps de mémorisation mécanique
d'exception ânonner pour ebook ayew tout
ce temps pourrait être converti en temps
de pratique de découverte de réflexion
de littérature ou d'histoire de la
langue donc en un sens la simplification
constitue bien un nivellement par le
haut
alors la question d'orthographe touche
aussi celle de l'accès à l'emploi
dans ces cas là aujourd'hui on sait ce
que coûte une faute d'orthographe
et puis vous imaginez si ce n'est pas
votre langue maternelle ou si vous êtes
dyslexiques
on emploie aussi l'orthographe pour
disqualifier une pensée sur internet par
exemple on voit souvent les commentaires
du genre va d'abord ce n'est cette
orthographe et après tu te permettra de
donner ton avis donc on empêche
quelqu'un de s'exprimer à cause de son
orthographe et donc on est bien face à
une forme de discrimination que tout le
monde trouve légitime
même ceux qui en sont victimes la trouve
légitime une sorte de syndrome de
stockholm et tout ça n'est possible que
si c'est orthographe est sacrée le
gréviste la grammaire devient la bible
tout ce qui s'y trouve
c'est parole d'évangile si c'est un
bescherelle ainsi soit-il simplifier
l'orthographe
ce serait appauvrir la langue donc ça
veut dire lui faire perdre de la valeur
mais de quelles valeurs est ce qu'on
parle on ne parle pas de la valeur de
l'orthographe
on parle de valeur tout court et si
l'orthographe française était un dogme
quand vous faites une faute on ne juge
pas votre orthographe
on vous juge vous sur base de votre
orthographe en 16 294 dans les cahiers
préparatoire du tout premier
dictionnaire de l'académie française il
est écrit l'orthographe servira à
distinguer les gens de lettres des
ignorants et des simples femmes
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]